President Trump has vowed to sign an
executive order ending birthright
citizenship a loophole by which foreign
nationals game the u.s. immigration
system critics on both the left and the
right are calling foul but the strategy
is both just and brilliant I'm telling
you I will explain why then the leftist
pots are calling conservative kettles
black on anti-semitism in America she
accused Julia
Yaffa accuses the president of
radicalizing more people than Isis and
two lesbians carry the same baby to term
that's it I'm leaving to the merrier
I'm Michael knows this is the Michael
Nolt show
[Music]
that last story really snuck up on me I
forgot that wasn't the show today that
will save that for dessert that'll be
nice dessert on our political dinner
that we're all having together it's nice
to be back it's very nice to be back
here in the broom closet I was on the
road for a little over a week we went to
Grand Canyon University we went to
Augustana University we went to the
University of Alabama in Huntsville it
was a ton of fun stopped by New York and
did Fox and Friends it was a great time
the students were fabulous
I had a cigar with the students last
night right in front of the no smoking
sign on campus that was really enjoyable
we talked about a few things we did
speeches on the culture we did speeches
on economics we're gonna be having a lot
more speeches coming up again if you
want me to stop by your school and cause
mayhem you should do it through yeah
whew should this the store is all being
hosted by the young America's Foundation
and it's been a ton of fun and now I
come back and president Trump is giving
the United States one of the greatest
civics lessons in a very long time by
threatening to sign an executive order
ending birthright citizenship we will
get to that in one second but first I am
so so pleased to well make a little
money honey and thank this wonderful new
sponsor operation American gratitude how
often do we talk on this show about the
dearth of patriotism and gratitude
especially among Millennials especially
because they're just not raised with an
appreciation of their country they're
raised to protest their flag to protest
their country operation American
gratitude is terrific it was founded
when the when the founder heard a
Vietnam veterans say on a podcast that
he had never been welcomed home in 50
years since returning to Vietnam since
returning from Vietnam the goal here is
to deliver thank you cards to two
million Vietnam veterans over the next
five years and play so you are not
forgotten card on every Vietnam War
Memorial in America my own grandfather
is a Vietnam veteran Purple Heart and so
it's a cause that's near and dear to my
heart this is this is really important
so what this does when you when you sign
up at raising Americans calm slash cough
FA CE o V Fe Fe you'll get a thank you
cards for five Vietnam veterans in your
tanyon interview of Vietnam veteran card
you are not forgotten card a Pio wmia
card a 58 220 card to honor all those
who made the ultimate sacrifice if you
don't know any no problem you can see
the Vietnam veteran hats on the street
100% of the profit from Operation
American gratitude goes toward building
the freedom never sleeps business
training center in beautiful Eagle Idaho
which is on site a six month paid
entrepreneurship training program for
veterans underprivileged youth I could
go on forever it's a wonderful thing
make life better for Vietnam veteran and
teach young Americans gratitude all for
less than 20 bucks
better yet participate alongside
Operation American gratitude makes you
fifty percent more likely to meet George
Washington in heaven that's a true story
adds that is proven go right now raising
Americans calm / co' FFA CA V Fe Fe buy
your operation American gratitude kit
raising Americans calm / cough FAC of EF
EF e and god bless america
terrific terrific sponsor you should
definitely do it so I come back I
actually didn't even get to come back
for this I was just on the airplane this
morning on my airplane Wi-Fi one of the
miracles of modern free market
capitalism there our economic system and
I saw the president Trump is now
threatening to end birthright
citizenship of course the left is up in
arms
some critics on the right or up in arms
are saying oh my gosh this is the end of
the American experiment our founders and
our framers they started this country
they rebelled against British rule so
that the children of foreign nationals
can access the modern American welfare
state that's why we fought the war in
1776 baby is so that people could come
here on birth tourism enter our country
illegally have children and access
American welfare programs yeah that's
what Patrick Henry said he said give me
birthright citizenship for the children
of foreign nationals to access welfare
programs or give me death is that what
he said forget I don't remember it's
been a while since I've read the history
books here is President Trump
explaining his proposed policy to Axios
on HBO on immigration some legal
scholars believe you can get rid of
birthright citizenship without changing
the Constitution executive order exactly
right have you thought about
yes tell me more it was always told to
me that you needed a constitutional
amendment you don't you don't number one
number one you don't need that number
two next thing to see you very much as
well you can definitely do it with an
act of Congress but now they're saying I
can do it just with an executive order
now how ridiculous were the only country
in the world where a person comes in has
a baby and the baby is essentially a
citizen of the United States for 85
years with all of those benefits it's
ridiculous it's ridiculous and it has to
end
have you talked about that with counsel
yeah so we're in the process in the
process it'll happen
we got an executive order that's what
you're talking about yes exactly I
didn't think anybody but knew them but
me I thought I was the only one Jonathan
I could guess good terrific excellent
timing excellent strategy for a few
reasons
one concern some conservatives are
calling foul they're saying you can't do
this through an executive order he has
to do with religious Latian or a
constitutional amendment or this or that
or the courts have to decide yes I agree
the the answer is the last one but what
is this all about this entire executive
order is not about actually changing the
the law of the land this executive order
is about asking the courts to finally
define birthright citizenship so the the
concept of birthright citizenship the
concept of anchor babies it comes from
the Fourteenth Amendment specifically
this line all persons born or
naturalized in the United States and
subject to the jurisdiction thereof are
citizens of the United States and of the
State wherein they reside okay what was
the purpose of this amendment to make
slaves former slaves citizens that's the
purpose of it that the purpose of it was
to revise to undo the the Dred Scott
decision which said that blacks can't be
citizens and this says all persons born
or naturalized in the United States
former slaves and subject to the
jurisdiction thereof are citizens of the
US now that the key phrase here is and
subject to the jurisdiction thereof
meaning that this
excluded Native Americans very
specifically it excluded Native
Americans who were subject to their own
jurisdiction their own tribal
jurisdiction this excluded the children
of diplomats who happened to be here if
a diplomat was visiting the United
States as children were born here they
did not have birthright citizenship this
excluded foreign nationals certainly the
foreign nationals who come to the u.s.
from Mexico or Guatemala or Honduras or
wherever certainly they are not subject
to the jurisdiction of the United States
they're subject to the jurisdiction of a
foreign entity so at no point during the
ratification of the Fourteenth Amendment
did its authors or the public believe
that this was to give birthright
citizenship to foreign nationals who
just happened to be in the United States
at the time the trouble is this has
never really been challenged there was a
court case I think in 1898 which defined
birthright citizenship for a Chinese
national for pair I think the parents
had legal status in the US but they
weren't citizens and the kid who was
born got birthright citizenship and this
is accelerated in recent years but it's
never really been defined so President
Trump said he's going to take away
birthright citizenship through an
executive order this is probably the
best way to do this I think it's better
than legislation this is the best way to
do it because ultimately because this is
a matter of constitutional
interpretation this is going to come
down to a court case this is going to be
defined by the Supreme Court this is why
it was very important to elect Donald
Trump over Hillary Clinton because
President Trump and cocaine Mitch have
gotten a zillion federal judges on the
bench and - excellent Supreme Court
justices so we've now got conservative
originalist justices on the bench and at
the federal courts who could define this
if President Trump tried to go through
the legislative process to take away
birthright citizenship which should be
taken away we'll go into that in a
second but - to take away this fictional
right to birthright citizenship first of
all it would bog down the Congress
forever they'd get nothing else done we
wouldn't get more tax cuts we wouldn't
get what is being hinted at is the
possibility of entitlement reform we
wouldn't get any of those things it
would bog them down it we would prob
lose certain legislators in in swing
districts it would be it would be
demagogued constantly would be
demagogues taking away citizenship from
Americans is taking away citizenship
from poor little kids or something it
would be a real mess and it would
ultimately be challenged in the courts
anyway so wouldn't actually get us any
further than this executive order will
at least by doing this executive order
first of all it's immediately going to
be challenged in and probably be stopped
or suspended by a left-wing court and
then it's gonna work its way up and
eventually make it to the Supreme Court
that's probably what has to happen you
know 150 years later you know a century
and a half later it's probably time that
we define what the 14th amendment has to
say about birthright citizenship there's
an argument to be made for either side
fine but certainly at the time of the
ratification of the 14th amendment it
was not considered that the 14th
amendment gave birthright citizenship to
Guatemalan Nationals who happen to be in
the United States or Chinese nationals
for that matter so I can't wait for it
to go through the courts it's also great
timing because the midterms are coming
up illegal immigration is a big winner
in the United States sovereignty is a
big winner issue in the United States
for conservatives and so that even the
timing is great but obviously obviously
if Donald Trump knows anything about
politics it's about the media of
politics it's about the cameras of
politics I will point out even in that
clip on HBO he's wearing a gold and
green tie I've been advocating this for
years I've been advocating the green tie
for years for Republicans I hate that we
have to wear red ties that they stuck us
with it was really Tim Russert who did
that they used to alternate between blue
and red for Republicans and Democrats
then sometime around the year 2000 they
decided I think was I actually sort of
blame Tim Russert for this that
Republicans were red and Democrats are
blue but red is awful we have bad
associations with red red is the color
of Communists red is the color of stop
signs and stoplights red is the color of
danger of fire and its associated with
Republicans which is absurd because the
Reds the commie pinko Reds are
are now the Democrat Party which has
embraced socialists 40 40 plus socialist
candidates across the country and
Alexandra Ocasio Cortese now running as
Jenny from the block even though she's
from Westchester
so I actually even love that he's
wearing that because green is the color
of money
Gold is the color of Donald Trump I
guess so it's a fine combination I hope
this is a sidebar but I really hope that
conservatives embrace that in the future
I also want to point out by making this
announcement on HBO not on Fox News not
on Fox & Friends
but on HBO you're triggering a huge
lefty audience and you're teaching a
civics lesson I've long said that
President Trump whether he knows
anything about our Constitution anything
about our system of government or checks
and balances or what the various
branches do I don't even care if he
knows about those he is the greatest
civics teacher that we have had
certainly in my lifetime probably in
modern American history because he is
forcing people to debate fairly basic
aspects of our government that have been
neglected before this what percentage of
the population would you say knew that
there is a long-standing debate over
what the Fourteenth Amendment says about
birthright citizenship two people three
people P the people in this room and the
people watching this show maybe very few
people knew that and now when Trump says
it you know President trumpet I love
this strategy I I love it when other
conservatives do this to to stake out
the extreme position and then you
trigger the other side into losing their
minds and taking a much more extreme
position on the other side and then
figuring out where the reality lies and
it in that situation it lies more on the
conservative side the argument for
birthright citizenship is pretty weak
and if there was an argument in in the
bygone days of Yonder now there's much
less of an argument because there's a
much more robust welfare state so
birthright citizenship implies a certain
a certain monetary value a certain
property value that comes at the expense
of native-born citizens or of
naturalized citizens so
I'm really glad we're having this debate
this gets back to the classic Trump move
that really started to win me over even
during the primary campaign when I was
very skeptical with him he was talking
to a reporter about the question of
anchor babies here is you mean it's not
politically correct and yet everybody is
is it I say you know what give me a
different term give me a different term
what else would you like to say you want
me to say that okay I'll use the word
anchor baby excuse me I'll use the word
anchor baby oh you want me to say the
future undocumented bird yeah you want
okay no I'm gonna say the word anchor
baby that's and he threw it into stark
relief we've all used the term anchor
baby Donald Trump didn't invent this
term we've used it for decades to
describe the process of people who come
to the United States well they're
pregnant when they're just about to give
birth to have the baby to get one of the
most valuable things on earth which is
American citizenship for their child in
part for what it'll do for the child and
in part then because it can stir chain
migration and bring the rest of the
family over when the kid has a US
citizenship and because it's you you
can't then deport the kid who has US
citizenship and you're probably not
going to deport his parents so the the
left has been youfo maizing this forever
so you all know we've got to use this
we've got to use this and he says no
it's anchor babies this is really
happening you know this is not president
drum sometimes exaggerate things
conservatives can exaggerate things this
is not being exaggerated there is such
an industry as birth tourism's
specifically among Chinese women
especially here in California we see it
there were articles going back way
before the Trump era way before Trump
was running for president which
described these compounds for birth
tourism and one one article about it
described them quote like a brothel in
Reverse which is a very sharp ssin I
think really does explain what it is
it's these women you get a dozen two
dozen women in a dirty room a filthy
room can you even imagine this
get a dozen or two dozen six-month
pregnant women oh dear god what hell on
earth that must be and they're all just
in this room together in these shabby
conditions dirt you know filth
everywhere and they're paying a ton of
money to do it in 2015 a year before the
2016 election there was a big article
about this quote The Tourist baby boom
bringing Chinese women to the u.s. to
have their babies as a growth business
and homeland security is cracking down
that wasn't homeland security under the
Obama administration that was homeland
security under or rather it wasn't
homeland security and the Trump
administration it was under the Obama
administration it was under a Democrat
government because it's it's a highly
immoral it's it's highly immoral to have
these women living in the shadows living
in filthy conditions just to exploit a
loophole in the present non enforcement
of our immigration regime it's also
criminal it's not criminal to come to
the United States if you're pregnant
that that one you still can do but it is
visa fraud to lie about your intentions
it is visa fraud to lie and say you're
going on vacation when really what
you're doing is staying in the US for
two or three months or four months to
have a baby and get US citizenship for
that baby it is lying when you say that
you're just going for the tacos or
something when really you've paid an
agency to set up a living condition for
you to have your child and exploit this
hole in the in the immigration system
you know as of 2012 the Center for
Immigration Studies estimated that
thirty six thousand pregnancy tourists
would come from around the world every
year just in 2012 thirty six thousand
that's not nobody I know that in a
country of 300 million that doesn't seem
like very much but for a relatively new
industry that is a that is a pretty
shocking number it shows that there are
pretty entrenched business interests
here and obviously this doesn't only
apply to Chinese women and Taiwanese
women this applies to Latin American
people who have been exploiting the
poorest port border with Mexico for
decades and not just them exploiting it
it's actually the left in America and
Democrats in America who were exploiting
those
people who desperately want to make it
to the US and encouraging them to commit
crimes to skip the line to undermine our
immigration laws and to make it over
here knowing that we're not going to
kick them out
this creates very very perverse
incentives and this empowers really bad
hombres to borrow a phrase from our
current immigration debate really bad
people get empowered by this because all
we were talking about this yesterday all
we see all the the left wants us to see
is the cute little baby shot at American
future cute low woman wants her son to
be pregnant or what yes we'll get to
that story later about the two pregnant
lesbians who carried the same child the
woman wants her son to have an American
future American citizenship right I
understand I love being an American it's
one of the one of the greatest blessings
one can imagine on earth but the country
can't support everybody and we need to
have laws we need to be a country in
laws that governs ourselves that also
allows people who are citizens to run
this country so when you've got these
awful incentives when you especially
with a welfare system such as ours which
is so so generous everywhere and an
immigration regime that isn't enforced
you you encourage these predators these
human traffickers these coyotes to bring
pregnant women across to bring young
girls across and we know from that study
from fusion and from Amnesty
International that 60 to 80 percent of
women and girls who were brought across
that border illegally or raped or
sexually assaulted that is a horrible
thing that you're encouraging but you
are encouraging it and even birthright
citizenship even just that is
encouraging the breaking of this law so
you've got to think who is birthright
citizenship helping it's helping illegal
aliens who are cutting the line who are
damaging or undermining our immigration
system who are disadvantaging people who
are doing their part and following the
rules and waiting in line it's it's
benefiting illegal aliens of another
sort who are these birth tourists who
fly in from China have the kid and fly
back it's benefiting coyotes
human smugglers and drug traffickers who
use these humans that their ferreting
across the border to carry drugs and to
bring crime in and to empower the
cartels down there and and and it's and
it's encouraging Democrats who want to
flood the country with illegal aliens
because they think statistically
eventually with an amnesty they'll get
more of those voters so and you know I'm
not saying that's in any particular
order by the way an order of how heinous
that is but it's really advantage
benefiting pretty terrible people
why would we continue that why would we
continue to leave that incentive there
when we could correct it when it's not
in the Constitution itself and I mean
this is this is a topic of serious
concern you know who's not concerned
though Shepard Smith I sometimes my
friends who are on the left they say oh
Michael I hate Fox News I never watch
fox but they always when they refer to
Fox News they're really referring to
every right-wing outlet Fox is just the
one that's on cable they said you know
but I kind of like Shepard Smith say
right you like the one the Democrat yeah
you like the left winger of the network
that's what no no he's at Fox no he is a
left winger and he's really really going
out pretty far these days here is
Shepard Smith talking about that that
caravan that's making its way up through
Latin America now whittled down to 5,000
from 14 down to seven now down to five
here is Shepard Smith's hot take on
tomorrow the migrants according to Fox
News reporting are more than two months
away if any of them actually come here
but tomorrow is one week before the
midterm election which is what all of
this is about there is no invasion no
one's coming to get you there's nothing
at all to worry about when they did this
to us got us all riled up in April
remember the result was 14 arrests where
America we can handle it yes that's
right Shepard there were only 14 arrests
which is a terrible thing because we
have a thousand people at least crossing
the border every single day that is
something to worry about
that is one because of everything we
just spoke about all of the the perverse
sentence of illegal immigration -
because of the cultural question of
assimilation we like to bring in a lot
of people into America we want people to
to send their best to quote the
president but assimilation is very
difficult under the best of
circumstances right now we have the
highest foreign-born percentage of the
population since 1890 I think 1880 or
1890 and that's very difficult when you
have half of the country discouraging
assimilation discouraging of becoming
Americans and entering into that melting
pot also we'll see when they get here
right now these some of these migrants
apparently the leaders of them are
demanding that Mexico pay for fast
transportation up to the United States
they're demanding quote safe and
dignified transportation from this
foreign government to bring them to
another foreign government so that they
can violate their immigration laws up
there so certainly that this group of
illegal aliens is not their best they're
trying to pretend that it's a bunch of
cute little children who would just want
a better life all of the people that
I've seen interviewed and I've watched a
lot of footage over the last week or two
these are guys I mean these are grown
men who are angry there was there was a
dispute at the Mexican border the
southern Mexican border the other day
people were injured it turned violent
so Shepard Smith is preening here he's
saying it's no big deal we should just
have open borders it were America it
doesn't matter we're America so
therefore we don't need an immigration
system or America so therefore we don't
have the right to control who enters our
country so he's preening about this I
wonder every time that Shepard makes one
of these comments how many votes does he
win for the Republican Party in the
midterms
how many every time he says come on stop
complaining about open borders like well
all right another 10,000 for the GOP oh
come on stop it it doesn't it doesn't
matter if foreign nationals invade your
country and lower wages particularly for
unskilled labor that doesn't matter
okay another tenth another 20,000 votes
for the GOP chalk it up keep it up I
really I really enjoy it when the left
is honest about what they really think
at least Shepard Smith won he's a pretty
entertaining broadcaster and - he's
honest about what he thinks he says yeah
it doesn't matter open borders crossed
the border doesn't
matter one little bit I don't care about
the law I don't care that you care about
the law I don't care how you want to
govern the country I want lawlessness
alright at least you're honest that's an
argument I would that the entire
Democrat Party were as honest as a
Shepard Smith it's a really unpopular
point of view but but but that's the one
that they're holding now and if only we
could go up to every Democrat running
for office and say what'll you do about
the caravan homina homina homina I mean
all of the I think Claire McCaskill
would be the only one at this point who
would actually say no keep them back
keep them back
but so many are now held hostage by the
base of their party the far-left base
and speaking about how everything is
Trump's fault I just that's just the
theme of today's show the several weeks
of shows probably until the midterms
were unsure about everything is Trump's
fault according to the left President
Trump is being criticized and blamed for
anti-semitism in America in the wake of
that shooting in Pittsburgh now where is
the anti-semitism in America we know
that President Trump is the most
pro-israel president probably in
American history they have a train
station dedicated to him in Jerusalem
you know he's his daughter as a convert
to Judaism his son-in-law is is being
put in charge of Middle East peace we
know that this guy is very very
pro-israel where is anti-semitism in
America though it's all on the Left it's
in the boycott divestment sanction
movement which holds that the Jewish
state is an apartheid government which
encourages students on campuses across
the country to to have their
universities divest pull money out of
Israel not participate in academic
conferences in Israel I think Stephen
Hawking before he died pulled out of an
academic conference because he hates
Israel that much the left the academic
and political left despised the Israeli
state recently at the University of
Michigan there were two professors who
refused to write letters of
recommendation for students to study in
Israel why because they hate the State
of Israel they don't consider it
legitimate they want it to disappear at
UC Irvine which is not very far from us
in Los
Angeles at UC Irvine they have an
anti-zionism week week imagine if you
went down to Irvine wearing a make
America great again hat probably they
would shut down the campus there would
be a hate crime alert that you'd be
expelled if you were a student at the
University but for a week they have
anti-zionism week which portrays Jews in
the Jewish state as monsters as tyrants
as oppressors that's where the
anti-semitism is how about Louis
Farrakhan remember I don't I don't I
mean there's there is the occasional
lunatic fringe on the right who or who
would call himself on the right who
hates Jews and hates Israel this guy who
shot up the synagogue in Pittsburgh
probably would call himself on the right
though it's worth pointing out he hates
Donald Trump and spoke at length about
how he hates Donald Trump and opposes
Donald Trump and didn't vote for Donald
Trump but you know probably in some
broad sense he would consider himself on
the right what about on the left they
associated with one of the worst hate
mongers in recent American history Louis
Farrakhan in his own words the Satanic
Jews they control everything and mostly
everybody you are not the chosen of God
you are the chosen of Satan I'm talking
about the wicked ones and in the Jewish
community that run America run the
government run the world own the bank's
own the means of communication they are
my enemies I just can't tell I just
can't what is this Louis Farrakhan think
about the Jews I just can't tell the
other day he wanted he said I'm not an
anti-semite
I'm anteater might you get it do you get
it that guy posed for pictures with
Barack Obama smiling oh he there's Obama
smiling right next to him the media
covered that picture up by the way for a
long time it was just in an event he was
at Aretha Franklin's funeral on on the
stage with Bill Clinton that's that's
that is the mains
REME of the left that's the mainstream
of the Democrat Party and the party
itself has turned against Israel in
recent years the GOP has full throated
ly embraced Israel wholeheartedly
embraced Israel and and more so even in
recent years why is that one their
reliable allies in in that region were
probably the only reliable ally in that
region - it's in our interest because we
get good intelligence from them they
help fight terrorism over in the Middle
East and also because of justice because
the Jewish state has a right to exist
and where is it going to exist it's
going to exist in the historic homeland
of the Jewish people that's it that's it
that is justice some people think it
would be justice if the Jewish state
were wiped off the face of the earth I
don't think that would be justice and I
don't think the people who claim to have
a right to that land have a right to
that land but it's certainly just for
the Jewish state to exist and it seems
that it should exist in the historical
homeland of the Jewish people that's the
position of conservatives that's the
position of Republicans not the position
of the left which seeks to destroy the
Jewish state and yet they spout this
idiocy all the time and then they turned
it up to 11 right before the midterms
you know the let they're so angry they
really thought that after Kavanagh the
GOP polling was gonna decrease it didn't
it went in the opposite direction they
were really they were really hoping that
there would be something that would it
would stop the Republicans from still
having momentum and so Julia eov is it I
offer yo if I only ever read her name
jaw a the jaw is that he brands that I
don't know loft
Koff I don't know Julia though Julie was
on CNN she's a writer for GQ and she
decided that she was going to turn her
hot takes up to 11 right before the
midterm elections I'll let her say it I
think you know this president one of the
things that he really launched his
presidential run on is talking about
Islamic Rattle radicalization and this
president has radicalized so many more
people than Isis ever did I mean the way
he talks the way he the way he that is
that just it's it's the way he talks
the way the way that he allows these the
way he winks and nods to these groups
what so how many people do we think Isis
radicalized how many like more than one
then they are then they radicalized more
than Donald Trump and probably Donald
Trump didn't even radicalize one what
she obviously doesn't mean this
literally how many countless Islamic
terrorists are roaming the earth killing
the innocent slaughtering the innocent
in evil acts how many how many thousands
how many over the course of history how
many millions very many how many has
Donald Trump radicalized what does she
mean by that what she's trying to do is
link Donald Trump to acts of violence so
we just had this this Pittsburgh
shooting at the synagogue the guy hated
Donald Trump that guy hated dumb Trump
what about the the guy in Florida the
most incompetent pipe bomber in all of
human history didn't even get one of
them to go off we still don't really
know anything about the guy other than
he's an ex-stripper homeless person did
he was here addict alized by Trump I
don't know he seemed to be pretty Looney
Looney Tunes before Donald Trump ever
came along but I guess he liked him so
how many were radicalized by Bernie
Sanders and shot up the Congressional
baseball game and almost killed Steve
Scalise how many how many was that how
many people were radicalized by them I
don't know how many people have been
radicalized by the left how many of
those mobs the screaming mobs in the
streets the ones who go to Republicans
houses and restaurants how many were
radicalized by the left far more far far
more and what's amazing is that on CNN
which says facts first I'm a banana
apples are bananas whatever their slogan
is they have on this woman Julia ye
yatha and she that they're presenting
her is the serious person I bet she went
to a good school
you know she's credentialed she has a
good credentials for magazines she's a
really serious person and she says
something but if a nine ninth grade
students said it you'd smack him and say
don't be so stupid
don't what a stupid thing to say and she
says that on CNN s oh wow mmm-hmm wow
yeah you said words yeah well really
really impactful talking about stupid
words impactful
so so that's the left they've got
nothing and obviously they're the boy
who cried wolf here they told us they
told us the sky would fall if Trump were
elected everything's gotten better so
now they're saying he's worse than Isis
okay what else you got what else you got
brick I can't wait until they tell us
more and and they try to say that he's a
white nationalist uh well we've got to
get to that once I get back from I've
got to send people over to daily
wire.com I'm sorry I have to do it we've
got that plus we've got the lesbian
couple that both carried the baby and
we've got goop we're gonna talk all
about goop and conscious conscious
uncoupling from Gwyneth Paltrow but you
can only get that if you go to daily
wire comm if you're on Facebook and
YouTube I'm amazed that they haven't
kicked you off yet go to daily wire comm
it's ten bucks a month $100 for an
annual membership you get me you get the
Andrew Clavin show you get the Ben
Shapiro show you get to ask questions in
the mailbag that's coming up on Thursday
you have to ask questions in the
conversation you get all that stuff it
doesn't matter this is what you get this
is this is a special collaboration
between The Daily wire and goop the
leftist here is all super porous organic
Xen crystal tumbler it's made out of
healing crystals that well they heal you
but the way that they heal you is from
the little salt crystals from left is
tears that hurt inside the tumbler so go
to daily wire calm to get the special
goop edition tumbler we'll be right back
with a lot more
I just like saying goop I that's mostly
why we're gonna move on to the goop
story just so I can keep talking about
goop
so goop goop is the company that Gwyneth
Paltrow founded and it's all natural and
it's so it's really good for the spirit
and the soul and it's all linked man so
anyway they are getting sued into
oblivion right now because they're
damaging people's lives and lying
blatantly on their website so the good
thinking Society which is a watchdog has
identified 113 misleading claims on the
goop website goop you know it's this
hippy dippy modern thing and Gwyneth
Paltrow by the way has already settled a
lawsuit over the porous Jade and quartz
egg which was used by women by very very
gullible and/or stupid women to treat to
endometriosis if you don't know what
that is don't google it and so anyway it
turns out that putting porous jade eggs
into your body is not terribly hygienic
I'm sure you know this is a family show
I don't want to scar children who might
be watching it anyway she she was able
to settle that lawsuit and now they're
getting dinged with a lot more
misleading claims I really like this
story because it just goes to show you
how hypocritical the apparently
pro-science left is you always hear
we're the party of science we believe in
science whatever that means they're the
same people who put crystals on their
chakras and read their horoscopes and
put Jade eggs where Jade eggs do not
belong and the reason for this is that
everybody's got to serve somebody and
that there is a metaphysical basis for
our physical sciences so you know all of
the pioneers of science were devout
Christians virtually all of them Newton
spent decades interpreting Scripture
Francis Bacon on and on and on if you
don't ground your physical science in
with a metaphysical foundation with a
strong tradition
metaphysical foundation you're going to
wander into these bizarro world
metaphysics of crystals and chakras and
witchcraft and whatever mysticism you
know there was another story that came
out that witchcraft is on the rise among
Millennials and anecdotally we know this
because there were though the Brooklyn
witches who put a hex on Cavanaugh and
all of these voxcom was encouraging
people to practice witchcraft apparently
though the statistics bear this out that
Millennials are leaning toward
witchcraft why is that it's because
you've got to serve somebody people have
a natural religious longing a longing
for the divine a longing for the
transcendent and when they've rejected
the religion of their civilization
they're cold they're the religion of
their culture the religion that created
their culture Christianity they're going
to fall for something else because that
longing will not go unsatisfied for very
long so here's from the GUP website here
is from our values quote we believe that
the little things count that good food
is the foundation of love and wellness
that the mind / body / spirit is
inextricably linked and we have more
control over how we express our health
than we currently understand now I will
point out that is technically a true
statement we do have more control over
our health than the people at GUP
understand absolutely true and they're
also identifying something true which is
that our bodies and our minds and our
spirits are inextricably linked some
people some modern people want to
pretend that we don't have a spirit or
we don't have a mind that we're just a
physical thing and other modern people
want to pretend that we're modern-day
Gnostics that the body is nothing it's
meaningless all that matters or ideas
but we know that actually we're both
soul and body that we're both flesh and
metaphysical and the GUP people
understand this they just take it in a
completely kooky direction they go on
quote our values we know who we are our
words and actions are aligned and we
take a curious unbiased open-minded and
service centric approach to what we do
we
test the waters so that you don't have
to god help whichever member of the
group staff tested the jade egg I hope
they got good workers comp for it I want
to focus on one word here they say that
they are open-minded they're curious
they're unbiased they're open-minded
they are biased and they are
closed-minded in some way to be
open-minded you have to be closed-minded
to be unbiased you have to arrive at
certain judgments and conclusions to be
open-minded you have to be willing to
conclude that certain ideas are wrong it
doesn't just mean if you're - if you're
completely open-minded if you're
open-minded and you won't make any
judgments then you'll be so open-minded
that your brain falls out of your head
you have to make certain judgments to be
open-minded is to entertain many ideas
but ultimately you have to reach
conclusions that's the only way you can
move on to other ideas and but they're
pretending that they don't have to do
that they're saying we're not biased
well what does that mean does that mean
you don't reach judgments certainly they
reached some judgments they decided that
the jade egg was better than the I don't
know crystal egg I don't know if it
really is but probably the crystal egg
would have been better who knows they've
reached that conclusion they've reached
that judgment they're pretending that
they haven't people are a little too
closed-minded open-minded in modern
society they're so closed-minded about
their definition of open-mindedness
they're not very open-minded they're so
tolerant that they don't tolerate
anything that disagrees with them you've
got to be able to reach conclusions
that's not wrong that's not harmful
that's not hurtful to say this is true
and this is false and moving on I'm not
gonna put a jade egg where a jade egg
should not be this brings us of course
to the Texas lesbians who are both
carrying the same baby how did they do
it I'll let them tell you themselves I
wanted to be pregnant for so long and so
bad I always wanted to have a child I
just didn't want to carry the child
Ashley and blitz new welcoming their own
biological child would require a sperm
donor and some creativity
obviously us being two women we were
like how can we make this happen we felt
like you know there has to be a way
there is a way for both women to carry
the same baby
alright I'll spare you the rest of that
and I'll give you the CliffsNotes
version which is that when people get in
vitro fertilization the way it happens
is that they'll go to a sperm bank
they'll get some sperm they will
incubate the sperm and the egg in a
little incubator for a little bit and
then they'll implant it into the mother
what this new process has done is taken
the sperm and the egg
they've incubated the sperm in the egg
in a little contraption inside one of
the women and then at the point when
they would typically implant this into
the mother they've taken it out of the
first woman and put it into the second
woman so the first woman really gets off
pretty easy here because she's only got
to carry the baby for like five minutes
and that you know for a week or however
long it is and then after that period
the other woman carries the baby for
nine months and they've both carried the
baby I'll tell you what I like about
this story what I like about this story
is the story acknowledges that the baby
is a baby because they're saying we've
both carried the baby we both carried
the baby in our wombs well wait a sec
arey the baby for a week you let you
carry the baby for a very small amount
of time the first woman only carried the
baby for a much shorter period of time
then the pro-abortion left wants to
pretend that the baby isn't a baby and
with this process these women are
admitting that one week BAE that two
week old baby is a baby then it goes
into the other woman that's the only
good thing I can say about this but I
will observe that this is totally
indicative of our culture which is
utterly self adoring it is looking
inward at one's self
it is only looking at one's personal
desires and personal needs to begin in
vitro fertilization results in multiple
eggs being fertilized multiple
infinitesimally small human beings being
begotten being created being begotten
rely really more precise to say begotten
and
then those are discarded the ones that
they don't want or discarded they're
either frozen or they're killed so
you've got brand new human life coming
together independent human life and then
being snuffed out that's the essential
problem with in vitro fertilization the
other problem here is that this baby is
being begotten for the desires of these
two women and that baby is being denied
the right to his father it's one thing
to say we're going to adopt a baby who's
been abandoned by his parents where we
were the parents don't think that they
can care for him or that the father ran
out because he's a degenerate or for
whatever reason we're gonna adopt this
baby that's taking a situation and
making it better in this situation you
were intentionally be getting a child
who will not know his father who will be
deprived of his father who will be
deprived of his natural right to his
parents that's awful that's a terrible
thing and we shouldn't encourage it as a
culture I understand why some people are
confused about this we should stop being
confused and we should speak clearly
about it then the entire aspect of this
is a woman says I really wanted to be
pregnant but I didn't want to have to be
pregnant for that long oh well I was
willing to be pregnant for a little bit
as long as we could be pregnant in this
way and then and I want this and I want
this and all through the night I'm in
Miami Miami my butt be getting a child
having a child isn't not about you it's
about the child it's about passing on
human life this great gift of human life
that we have been given from God through
our parents we're giving it to somebody
else for them for them to have life not
for you not for your enjoyment not so
that you can design a baby whole cloth
say oh it should look like this because
that's where we're getting to with four
well we've had selective abortions for a
long time
sex selective abortions abortions that
are designed to snuff out disabled
populations and very soon particularly
with the advance of gene therapy we'll
be able to choose eye colors we'll be
able to choose hair colors we'll be able
to choose this or choose that and the
way we'll choose it is by killing the
babies that we don't want and keeping
the babies that we do want and it's a
that's a morally repugnant situation
that's a situation where the baby is a
pet for the parents and we see when when
parents do this because we all know
parents who treat their children as
little pet
as little playthings just for them
especially you know you see it in
Hollywood with the stage parents who are
living vicariously through their kids
who are almost always miserable and
screwed up because of it and we
criticize it when we see it in parents
day to day and yet we're encouraging it
in this new technological and cultural
advance it's a really scary thing
it creates pretty funny little bizarre
clips on on news shows on the evening
news but you know this which is now
being seen as bizarre now will be
mainstream within six months or a year I
mean it's gonna happen really quickly
and we've got to speak with clarity
against it because it is all we look at
here is oh that's so nice those two
women love each other and now they can
now they can have this experience
together that they both wanted in the in
the beginning of a child but we're not
talking about the child and the rights
that the child should have and how the
child should be brought up and what the
purpose of having a child is and what
the process for having a child is okay
I'm getting off my soapbox I went
straight from LAX when I got in from all
those speeches to my soapbox here and
now I'm getting off my soapbox and going
to my purple mattress and going to bed
because I've been awake for about eight
days straight now and feeling a little
delirious and I'll probably be just as
delirious tomorrow so tune back in in
the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Knowles show I'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018